und jetzt das heute journal
am ende des finales sprang der triumph
von wembley nach rom die ewige stadt die
eine halbe ewigkeit ohne em hatte leben
guten abend not time for users keine
zeit für die verlierer
das st wien immerhin eine britische band
aber so denken wir nicht wir schauen auf
die seite der verlierer die heute mit
alten dämonen wieder kämpfen müssen
dämonen die 1 sieg ihrer jungen
unverbrauchten vielfarbigen löwen
mannschaft hätte auf den müllhaufen der
geschichte kicken können und es dann
verdammt knapp nicht schaffte und es
gibt dort auch noch einen premier der
schon vorab für nächsten montag den tag
der freiheit und unabhängigkeit von
corona ausgerufen hat so laut dass
johnson davon kaum noch und bekommt
diana zimmermann berichtet so groß die
erwartungen so hoch die hoffnungen so
selbstbewusst die engländer eine nation
im rausch bis zur 67
minute danach hofften sie weiter doch
vergeblich
fast unerträglich schmerzhaft das ende
des traums vom ersten titel nach 55
jahren
ich bin traurig aber trotzdem stolz wir
gewinnen die weltmeisterschaft wieder
bleibt nur die hoffnung aufs nächste mal
und ein nur zu vertrautes problem dass
wir wieder beim elfmeter verloren haben
ist einfach vernichten
die angst der engländer vom elfmeter
scheint so alt wie der fußball lange
glaubten sie sich regelrecht verflucht
nun war der befreiungsschlag in
greifbarer nähe
wollten sie endlich das trauma besiegen
und gleich noch 16 schreckliche monate
cupid vergessen lassen
doch dann
das bild des tages der erst 19 jährige
busacca getröstet von seinem trainer
gareth southgate verschoss vor 25 jahren
auch in wembley auch bei einer
europameisterschaft den entscheidenden
elfmeter gegen deutschland er weiß wie
es sich anfühlt die erwartungen von
millionen zu enttäuschen er hat es schon
zweimal getan
insgesamt drei spieler konnten nicht
verwandeln die wut der fans entlud sich
in rassistischen online angriffen und
auf diesem wandgemälde abscheulich
nannte nicht nur prinz william
diese vorfälle die spieler haben einen
unglaublichen zusammenhalt gezeigt und
in einem tollen geist gespielt das hat
so viele teile unseres landes zusammen
gebracht sie sind hoffentlich sehr stolz
auf das was sie geschafft haben dass
manche von ihnen beleidigt werden ist
unentschuldbar southgate nahm die
verantwortung für das spiel heute ganz
auf sich der premierminister will der
bei trotz steigender inzidenz in einer
woche den freedom day feiern
darauf er hat ein wenig siegesgewissheit
eingebüßt wir halten an unserem öffnungs
plan fest alle gesetze und
abstandsregeln aufzuheben aber wir
erwarten und empfehlen dass man etwa
masken in vollen geschlossenen räumen
trägt die engländer sollen nun also vor
allem selbst vernünftig sein ein
riskantes spiel
hunderte verschafften sich gestern etwa
ohne ticket und damit sicher auch ohne
kurve tests zugang zum ohnehin sehr
vollen stadion ein klarer sieg
der leidenschaft über die vorsicht was
beim fußball zum ziel führen kann hat
bei corona bisher immer nur für mehr
leid gesorgt und es ist immer ein fehler
sich zu früh zu freuen weiß jeder
passiert trotzdem fast jeden immer mal
wieder das ist jetzt aber kein tribut
dann diese binsenweisheit dass wir jetzt
auf den wahlkampf der grünen kommen
die haben öfter schon erlebt wie es ist
wenn man die größten höhenflüge weit vor
der wahl in umfragen erlebt und am
wahlsonntag ein rücksturz in bescheidene
realität das möchten sie diesmal nicht
nochmal haben dafür viel ballast
abgeworfen flügelkämpfe utopische
forderungen verbote als bevorzugtes
werkzeug der politik stattdessen kamen
dann die wie sie selbst sagen misst
stolperer ihrer frischen
kanzlerkandidatin die erinnerung daran
verblasst aber bleibt jetzt sollen
plakate parolen und themen des
wahlkampfes wieder gute laune und wind
unter die flügel bringen
andrea maurer bericht robert habeck auf
küsten tour in seinem bundesland
schleswig-holstein in seinem element
könnte man sagen
in den letzten wochen hat er sich
auffallend zurückgehalten es ist eine
gratwanderung er darf sich nicht zu sehr
von annalena baerbock distanzieren und
er darf die fehler nicht kleinreden
das war ja klar dass es gegenwind gibt
und schwierig wird aber die fehler haben
natürlich hier gemacht dass es da gibt
es kein grund um zu holen dass viele
hier auf sylt ihn für den besseren
kandidaten halten ist wohl einerseits
dem heimspiel geschuldet verschafft dem
termin aber andererseits auch
aufmerksamkeit
zum einen hat der regierungserfahrung
und obwohl er vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger faktensicher ist glaube ich wäre
er der bessere kandidat gewesen
die frage ist stellt sich mir gar nicht
die halle muss gefallen es geht darum
dass jetzt schlagfest ich genug ist und
welche themen vor der wahl jetzt
thematisiert werden ja mittlerweile
glaube ich schon dass er der bessere
kandidat ist weil aber glaube ich
einfach ein sauberen lebenslauf haben
unterdessen in berlin vorstellungen der
grünen wahlkampagne
die partei will optimismus verbreiten
bemerkenswert nur ein plakat zeigt
berbalk alleine das wort kanzlerin kommt
überhaupt nicht vor ob und wann sie noch
als kandidatin präsentiert wird
entscheidet sich erst in der letzten
kampagne phase heißt es wir sind ein
starkes duo für diese bundestagswahl mit
annalena baerbock und robert habeck und
in seiner kampagne strategie gehört
natürlich auch dazu dass man ende dann
noch weiter personell zuspitzt frank
stauss ist politikberater und macht seit
über 30 jahren wahlkampagnen vor allem
für die spd er sehe sofort wenn einer
kampagne schwierigkeiten hat sagt stauss
wenn man die produktionsprozesse von
plakaten kennt dann weiß man dass jetzt
die plakate gedruckt werden müssen die
in wenigen wochen für die bundestagswahl
im ganzen land stehen
das ist gleichzeitig das medium dass man
am wenigsten dann verändern kann und das
ist für mich ganz klar dass diese
kampagne ein problem hat sie vermeidet
es annalena baerbock als
kanzlerkandidatin zu benennen und das
bedeutet für mich dass ich die kampagne
ein hintertürchen offen lässt ob da noch
ein wechsel stattfinden wird
annalena baerbock selbst ist diese woche
noch im urlaub die schlagzeilen sind
weiter nicht gut
berbalk bittet um prüfung ob sie für ihr
promotionsstipendium rechtmäßig 40.000
euro erhalten hat und die faz hat in
ihrem buch auch grobe inhaltliche patzer
entdeckt wieder in die offensive kommen
darum geht es jetzt für die grünen die
kontrolle zurückgewinnen auch die über
die bilder wie robert habeck heute beim
besuch dieser flug windkraftanlage die
strom mit fliegenden drachen erzeugt
wahlkampfmodus wie man an den drachen
sieht er bewegt sich immer
so eine art sinuskurve das heißt wenn
man uns geht es auch wieder hoch und wir
sind ja gar nicht wirklich unten wir
sind irgendwie 20 prozent - also das ist
alles voll in den rachen kurve und die
sachen kugel wird uns dann auch
rechtzeitig genau in die höhe wirft
führen dass er als kanzlerkandidat
übernimmt dementiert habe ich in diesem
sommer dreht sich der wind hat der
annalena baerbock noch im juni auf dem
parteitag versprochen und einen
politikwechsel gemeint inzwischen ist es
ein wunsch den ihre partei selbst hat
dass sich der wind dreht
raus aus der flaute und annalena
baerbock ist die einzige frau unter den
drei menschen die sich vorstellen können
im herbst ins kanzleramt zu ziehen
das heißt ja immer noch so wenn ihr das
nicht gelingt dann wird nach 16 jahren
kanzlerin merkel plötzlich klar sichtbar
wie niedrig der frauenanteil in der
deutschen politik ist
die kanzlerin hat das bild lange
überstrahlt auch in ihrer eigenen partei
wenn sie dann abtritt werden dort kaum
noch frauen in der ersten reihe stehen
ein phänomen
man kann auch sagen ein relikt aus
überwunden geglaubten zeiten auf allen
ebenen des politischen lebens in
deutschland wie dort bewerber fest
stellt
sie ist die erste hier im amt mit 34
jahren
elisa dickmann ist bürgermeisterin von
coesfeld und parteilos 66 prozent der
stimmen hat sie bei der wahl vergangenes
jahr erhalten und sprüche als frau ich
würde nur gewählt werden weil ich hübsch
bin auf den plakaten
ich habe mich gefragt ich habe ein
gesicht auf einem wahlplakat gehabt ich
habe noch nie jemanden gesehen der ein
wahlplakat anders dargestellt hat aber
wenn ich das mache ist das eine
selbstdarstellung wenn das anfang macht
das ganz normal politik eine
männerdomäne
gerade einmal neun prozent der
bürgermeister sind frauen es gibt nur
zwei ministerpräsident innen und im
bundestag ist der frauenanteil von 36,5
in der vergangenen legislaturperiode auf
31 4 prozent gesunken
claudia roth ist seit 2013 vize
präsidentin des deutschen bundestags sie
bemerkte schon das ist wenig frauen im
parlament gebe und der parlamentarische
alltag für frauen habe sich seit dem
einzug der afg gewandelt es hat sich
absolut verändert das ist aggressiver
geworden es ist an machender geworden
die ehrlich gesagt ich habe bei manchen
kollegen das gefühl dass nachdem klar
war dass angela merkel nicht mehr
antreten wird sich jetzt die männer
wieder ja dass so ein aufatmen kommt so
jetzt kommen wir wieder zurück in die
alten richtigen verhältnisse
16 jahre lang war angela merkel
regierungschefin in ihrer partei der cdu
liegt der frauenanteil im bundestag noch
unter dem durchschnitt bei 21 prozent
warum ist das so es kommt auf das
nominierungsverfahren an innerhalb der
parteien
davon hängt ab ob frauen eine chance
haben nominiert zu werden und dann auch
gewählt werden zu können
die einführung einer frauenquote bei der
cdu vertagt für eine solche quote hatte
sich ex parteichefin angriff kramp
karrenbauer seit jahren eingesetzt
vergeblich wenn man sich ein system
volkspartei wie das der cdu anschaut das
funktioniert eigentlich alles irgendwie
immer nach quoten es wird geschaut wir
sind die konfession zugehörigkeiten
arbeitnehmer unternehmer aus welchem
ortsteil kommt jemanden das ist auch nie
ein problem wird auch nie diskutiert
außer wenn es um frauen geht die
strukturen sind weiter männlich geprägt
auch im wahljahr 2021 frauen in der
politik eine minderheit
und das war nur ein ausschnitt aus dem
gros thema frauen in der politik damit
beschäftigt sich die doku unter männern
von dr färber und sebastian galle
jederzeit auch jetzt schon in der
mediathek im zdf fernsehen dann am
mittwochabend 22 45 nach heute-journal
und auslandsjournal und hier bei uns nur
nachrichten von gundula gause
während in england also ab dem 19
juli alle verbliebenen corona
beschränkungen weitgehend aufgehoben
werden setzt frankreich wieder auf
striktere maßnahmen wegen der delta
variante gebe es einen wettlauf mit der
zeit erklärte präsident makro in einer
fernsehansprache
dabei kündigte er eine impfpflicht für
mitarbeiter von krankenhäusern alten-
und pflegeheimen an
ab dem 15 september werde kontrolliert
ob das personal in diesen bereichen
geimpft sein
zur beurteilung der pandemie lage in
deutschland will
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
neben der sieben tage inzidenz auch die
zahl der in krankenhäusern behandelten
corona patienten einbeziehen
ab morgen soll neben der auslastung der
intensivstationen mit corona patienten
auch die schwere des krankheitsverlaufs
und der impfstatus der patienten
dokumentiert werden
die deutsche krankenhausgesellschaft
warnte vor mehrbelastungen durch weitere
datenerhebungen polizeianwärter in
hessen sollen künftig regelmäßig vom
verfassungsschutz überprüft werden
das hat eine expertenkommission
empfohlen die im auftrag der
landesregierung vorschläge zur reform
der polizei entwickelt hat
das gremium empfahl zudem fehlverhalten
der beamten künftig auch öffentlich zu
kommunizieren
das vertrauen in die polizei hatte
schaden genommen als jets bekannt wurden
in denen polizisten rechtsextreme
inhalte teilten auch sollen
informationen aus polizeidatenbanken
genutzt worden seien um drohbriefe zu
verschicken
bundesinnenminister seehofer hat einen
der deutschen ableger der kriminellen
rocker gruppe bandidos mit sofortiger
wirkung verboten anfang juli waren bei
razzien dort waffen drogen und bargeld
sichergestellt worden
in nordrhein westfalen durchsuchten
einsatzkräfte vereinsräume und
demontierten schenker ziel der
gruppierung bandidos mce federation west
central sei nicht wie behauptet
gemeinsames motorradfahren
die behörden werfen einigen mitgliedern
schwere straftaten wie körperverletzung
sowie tötungsdelikte vor etwa 650 rocker
sollen von dem verbot betroffen sein
erstmals seit jahrzehnten ist es im
sozialistischen karibikstaat kuba zu
massenprotesten gekommen tausende wagten
sich in mehreren städten auf die straßen
und demonstrierten gegen
mangelwirtschaft und politische
unterdrückung mehrere menschen wurden
festgenommen
kubas präsident jack scannell macht die
usa für die proteste verantwortlich
dem von der kommunistischen partei seit
mehr als 60 jahren regierten kuba hat
sich die wirtschaftskrise in den
vergangenen monaten deutlich verschärft
in südafrika ist es bei den tagelangen
protesten gegen die inhaftierung von ex
präsident zuma zu blutigen
ausschreitungen gekommen
die regierung entsandte jetzt soldaten
in zwei provinzen um die polizei bei der
eindämmung der unruhen zu unterstützen
bei straßenschlachten und plünderungen
kamen sechs menschen ums leben
der unter korruptionsverdacht stehende
summe musste am mittwoch eine
15-monatige haftstrafe antreten weil er
zu einer gerichtlichen befragung nicht
erschienen war
deutschland und seine kanzlerin haben
heute schwierigen besuch
wolodimir selensky präsident der ukraine
der mann der als tv schauspieler und
komiker bekannt und dann staatschef
wurde
für ihn ist deutschland ein verbündeter
mit dem er probleme hat die bald fertige
zweite direkt gas pipeline von russland
nach deutschland könnte die ukraine vom
lukrativen transit geschäft abschneiden
er will nord stream zwei stoppen
obendrein will er von deutschland
rüstungsgüter gegen russlands präsenz an
und in der ost ukraine
beides kann oder will angela merkel ihm
nicht geben
das muss sie heute ihm noch mal klar
machen und am donnerstag dann joe biden
in washington ohne dem einen oder dem
anderen oder gar beiden auf die füße zu
treten
ein politisches tänzchen ohne fehltritt
wäre jetzt fällig bitte es begann für
selensky heute beim kollegen präsidenten
andreas künast berichtet es geht nicht
nur um eine pipeline sondern auch um ein
gefühl das hat der bundespräsident
zuletzt im februar erfahren als er nord
stream 2 und die toten des zweiten
weltkriegs in einem satz unterbrachte
die empörung in der ukraine lebt bis
heute nach präsident steinmeier gehört
zu den entschiedensten verteidiger der
pipeline präsident salewski zu den
verzweifelten gegnern die frage des
tages was jetzt bei bundespräsident
steinmeier kanzlerkandidat laschet bei
kanzlerin merkel für selent ski ist das
wichtigste dass die deutschen verstehen
warum nord stream 2
das sicherheitsgefühl seines landes
verletzt die ukraine ist überzeugt dass
russland eine gas transit region nicht
angreifen wird
mit nord stream 2 wächst die potenzielle
bedrohung der sicherheit der ukraine und
der region davon zeugt auch die
konzentration der russischen truppen an
der ukrainischen staatsgrenze
aber schließlich nicht es geht nicht nur
um die pipeline sondern um das gefühl
dass deutschland russland besser
versteht als die ukraine sei lenz kies
gesprächspartner sind für die deutsch
russische pipeline und gegen deutsch
ukrainische militärhilfe dazu kommen
viele die auch das letzte druckmittel
die sanktionen gegen russland aufheben
wollen vor allem ministerpräsidenten vor
allem aus dem osten ja die sanktionen
wirken gar nicht sondern sie werden in
vielfältiger art und weise umgangen und
deswegen muss man auf andere instrumente
kommen gerade was nützt ihm zwei angeht
haben wir auch ganz klar gesehen dass
amerika das auch für eigene
wirtschaftliche zwecke missbraucht
amerika hat in den vergangenen wochen
den druck gelockert präsident biden
verzichtet auf sanktionen gegen die nord
stream zwei betreibergesellschaft am
donnerstag will er mit merkel in
washington eine gemeinsame position
finden
die frage ist was bietet deutschland
merkel sagt zielinski am abend mehr zu
als sie selbst erfüllen kann eine
vereinbarung die russland zum
langfristigen gas-transit zwingt das
werden wir auch so wie wir es jetzt bis
2024 durchsetzen als europäische union
und deutschland durchsetzen für die
zukunft ich glaube da sind wir nicht
ohne macht und das haben wir der ukraine
versprochen und daran werden wir uns
auch halten und ich pflege meine
versprechung zu halten und ich glaube
das gilt auch für jeden weiteren
deutschen bundeskanzler
es fehlen nur noch wochen vielleicht
tage bis nord stream 2 fertig ist der
ukraine fehlt deutschlands zuversicht
und deutschland fehlt das gefühl warum
und der großen politik in die kleine und
auch die ihr ist sehr wichtig wenn man
dort nicht lebt müsste man sich nicht
unbedingt dafür interessieren dass die
verwaltung im landkreis
anhalt-bitterfeld von einem cyber
angriff lahmgelegt wurde
schon letzten dienstag mit dem
hochfahren der rechner damals kam alles
zum stillstand
das kann das vorspiel für eine
erpressung sein freigabe der server
gegen lösegeld
so läuft das in der regel und so läuft
das
immer öfter 108.000 angriffe im
cyberraum in deutschland letztes jahr
meist verwaltungen und firmen meist
erpressung
jetzt also anhalt bitterfeld das ist
kein einzelfall
das ist eine warnung mal
sicherheitssysteme in deutschland zu oft
lachnummern sind und damit eine große
gefahr
stellen sie sich vor dass
lebensmittelläden massenweise so
lahmgelegt werden für tage und wochen
erinnern sich daran was los war als es
nur am anfang den pandemie um klopapier
ging und plötzlich würden lebensmittel
knapp weil niemand sie bestellen liefern
bezahlen kann ohne elektronik und
deshalb ist was hagen nicolas berichtet
eine warten nichts geht mehr an den
rechnern der gesamten landkreis
verwaltung seit fast einer woche ist
nahezu jeder der 900 beschäftigten
offline neben fax und brief bleibt für
verwaltungs anfragen nicht viel
ich mache es kurz es geht die
telefonanlage
alles andere ist out of order der leider
momentan wir versuchen parallel jetzt
ein notsystem auf die beine zu stellen
ausgerechnet jetzt ein amtswechsel
landrat grabner hat heute seinen ersten
tag nach medieninterviews folgt die
nächste große krisensitzung denn ein
schadprogramm hat die server des
landkreises anhalt-bitterfeld
vergangener woche infiltriert und die
daten verschlüsselt um hilfe zu bekommen
rief der scheidende landrat noch am
freitag den katastrophenfall aus
wenn man bedenkt wie viel personen
spezifische daten trotz entsprechend
gelagert sind oder dort verarbeitet
werden denn natürlich darüber hinaus wie
viele personen über das jugendamt oder
sozialamt oder andere dinge entsprechend
mit geld versorgt werden also dahin viel
dran leistungen wie wohn kinder oder
hartz iv gelder will der landkreis nun
erst einmal unbürokratisch per vorkasse
zahlen
offen hingegen wann genau auf welchem
weg der virus ins system kam und wie
viele bereiche betroffen sind
expertinnen des landeskriminalamtes und
des bundes ermitteln derzeit bis zu
einem ergebnis könne es tage oder wochen
dauern
sind unmengen von daten sichergestellt
worden und diese müssen jetzt mit
entsprechenden mit mit entsprechenden
technischen und software-unterstützung
untersucht werden wir gehen davon aus
dass es sich um einen run zum br angriff
handelt das heißt also das ziel ist die
verschlüsselung von daten und das ist
natürlich immer auch mit geldforderungen
verbunden der landkreis
anhalt-bitterfeld sei beispielhaft sagt
manuela ad hoc vom chaos computer club
das zeigten die zunehmenden cyber
angriffe auf öffentliche infrastrukturen
weil eben die it-sicherheit in denen in
den kommunen natürlich am ende der kette
am unsichersten ist es gibt die bundes
umgebung die landes umgebung und dann
kommen die kommunalen umgebung und
insgesamt ist die it sicherheit da halt
eher unter durchschnitt investitionen in
it systeme und mehr fachkräfte gerade in
landkreisen und kommunen wären nötig der
landkreis anhalt bitterfeld ist derweil
weiter um schadenbegrenzung bemüht aus
seinem daten backup und mithilfe
benachbarter landkreise soll die
verwaltung zunächst ein notprogramm
erhalten
wir werden uns über einen zeitraum von
drei bis sechs monaten gedanken machen
müssen bevor das system endgültig wieder
so läuft wie es vor dem angriff gelaufen
ist zeit die vom kleinen landkreis noch
viel arbeit und von seinen bürgern
weiterhin geduld erfordert und wir
bleiben in der digitalen welt der
nachrichtendienst whatsapp wird weltweit
von mehr als zwei milliarden menschen
genutzt sie alle mussten vor kurzem neue
regeln akzeptieren und werden
mehrheitlich nicht verstanden haben
warum walhalla und deswegen hat ein
europäischer verbraucherverband jetzt
beschwerde eingelegt stichwort
datenschutz ja datenschutz ist ein
aspekt in die verbraucherschützer prüfen
lassen wollen weiterer kritikpunkt ist
dass vielen nutzern überhaupt nicht klar
war was sich eigentlich konkret ändert
mit den neuen regeln
die beschwerde ist insgesamt 27 seiten
lang und die liegt jetzt bei der eu
kommission
und darin kritisieren
verbraucherschützer whatsapp habe seine
nutzer hartnäckig und unangemessen unter
druck gesetzt die neuen regeln unklar
formuliert außerdem habe man bedenken
hinsichtlich der privatsphäre
auslöser der
kritik war die einschätzung dass mit dem
update mehr daten mit der konzernmutter
facebook geteilt werden sollen whatsapp
weist dies zurück der chat dienst ist
der platzhirsch unter den messenger
diensten mit den weltweit meisten
nutzern auch die deutschen verwenden
whatsapp laut bundesnetzagentur mit
abstand am häufigsten die marktmacht ist
riesig sie geht in einigen ländern so
weit dass firmen ihre kunden
dienstleistungen ausschließlich über
whats app anbieten flüge buchen zum
beispiel inzwischen gelten die neuen
regeln sie sind von anfang an auf
heftige gegenwehr gestoßen auch bei den
eigenen nutzern whatsapp rivalen wie
single oder dreamer konnten davon
profitieren sie erlebten zeitweise einen
riesigen ansturm was freilich nicht
heißt dass die nutzer gleichzeitig wort
erlöschen aber ganz machtlos ist der
user eben auch nicht gegen die
marktmacht des riesen vielen dank
valerie nach rund dreißig jahrelangen
sanierungsarbeiten ist in görlitz die
synagoge als kulturzentrum wieder
eröffnet worden
der neue raum bewahre und ermögliche
jüdisches leben erklärte sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmann und
forderte zu friedlichem miteinander auf
auch kulturstaatsministerin grütters
würdigte die bemühungen für die
sanierung des jugendstilbaus und die
dort geplante dauerausstellung in der
synagoge sollen kulturveranstaltungen
stattfinden und auch wieder
gottesdienste im vergangenen jahr der
hunger in der welt deutlich zugenommen
nach angaben mehrerer un organisationen
haben die wirtschaftlichen einbrüche als
folge der pandemie zum schlimmsten
anstieg des hungers seit jahrzehnten
geführt um die 800 millionen menschen
knapp ein zehntel der weltbevölkerung
waren demnach unter ernährt bis zu 160
millionen mehr als im vorjahr
und auch zu diesem wochenbeginn gibt es
unwetterwarnungen des deutschen
wetterdienstes in teilen von nordrhein
westfalen rheinland pfalz baden
württemberg und dem saarland muss mit
ergiebigem dauerregen gerechnet werden
die extreme hitze im westen der usa
dauert an
die waldbrände breiten sich aus vor
allem in oregon und kalifornien hunderte
hektar stehen in flammen
nach den verheerenden bränden des
vergangenen jahres stehen viele regionen
erneut vor einem katastrophensommer 200
menschen sollen bereits an der hitze
gestorben sein
die behörden warnen vor
gesundheitsgefahren im death valley
wurden 56 grad gemessen
gouverneur rief den notstand aus die
hitze sei folge des klimawandels
das war es für heute von uns wir
wünschen noch einen schönen abend und
sehen uns wurden bitte zuvor noch der
hinweis auf nasa ägypter mir und unser
heute-journal update sie melden nicht um
23 35
[Musik]
guten abend das unwetter tief dann wird
uns die ganze woche beschäftigen mit
dauerregen und mit heftigen gewittern es
vermischt nämlich sehr heiße luft aus
richtung südosteuropa mit kühlerer luft
aus richtung atlantik von alldem merken
sie im nordosten nicht denn dieser dauer
regen mit gewittern setzt sich jetzt in
der nacht über baden württemberg fest
zieht dann weiter richtung hessen
rheinland pfalz und das saarland und
erreicht morgen auch nordrhein westfalen
gleichzeitig gibt es auch kräftige
gewitter
hier in einem streifen von ostbayern bis
hinauf zum sauerland das kann morgen
abend heftig werden mit hagel mit
korngrößen von fünf zentimeter von all
dem gibt es im nordosten nichts zu
bemerken da funkeln die sterne bei
temperaturen von 18 bis 13 grad in
dieser nacht und auch morgen über tag
kann nordöstlich der elbe häufig die
sonne scheint an der grenze zum
dauerregen aber entwickeln sich die
heftigsten gewitter denn morgen gibt es
krasse temperaturunterschiede im osten
und im nordosten klettern die werte auf
28 bis 32 grad im dauerregen sind es
dagegen kaum 17 grad
und auch in den nächsten tagen geht es
mit diesen unwetter weiter mit kräftigen
regenfällen erst am freitag beruhigt
sich die lage und zu können punktuell
durch die gewitter und dem starkregen
durchaus 200 liter regen pro
quadratmeter zusammenkommen
kleinere bäche werden über die ufer
treten aber auch von größeren flüssen
wie zb rhein und main sollten sie sich
fernhalten
guten abend